welcome to this video playing wannabe GM
from Italy and note that i'm back on 23
it was yeah it wasn't the most
attractive chess all the time but i
regained enough points to at least have
23 here okay we have an English Defence
and I'm wired for a change hmm is he
going to play this crazy a 5-line a 5
this is a line that I have played myself
here really really really bonkers this
line is he's playing it and he's writing
to me a thanks for playing I've seen
many of your videos yeah that's nice
thanks yeah he does checking everyone I
know it looks it looks really wacky but
this is the way it is played it's um
it's interesting to play for both sides
actually black has some structural
problems but white has this bad King and
yeah it's a it's a very interesting
practical opening to complicate the
position okay the question is should i
take only six or not poor complicated
complicated i guess i should and i hope
that's not like it like punished
immediately hmm now that I think of it
through k 3
look f3 Queen F 392 oops and GF Knight
c3 and Bishop a freeroll tool well this
I didn't didn't even think of not not
the least not the least bit but if I
take 95 maybe I mean I would love to
play 7 of course okay come on take it
first I mean this cannot be too bad if
the Jedi agonal is some is closed at the
moment and I don't see a way for him to
I can ditch it with you three the pawn
but Bishop takes and next move I just
play Bishop e3 and it's a solid solid
structure and now this part is I mean I
can't cover it with Queen g4 maybe
depending on his move of course I mean
if he plays Queen f6 I might I might
need to to to cover f2 first and I must
give up the porn but term hmm this
should be three
yeah yeah come on come on keep it simple
keep it simple it's usually a very good
approach and let's just should I go
Quincy form to go for Queen trade c4 is
a week then I could also push the edge
porn well if he plays 97 and the
exchange I have the weakness with Queens
on the bond okay come on let's at least
be quick about those decisions and I
think he needs to trade moving the Queen
again seems like lots of Temple my queen
is not badly placed on g4 of course so
Queen f6 or something does not make much
sense I would just play age for awesome
I guess yeah he's right and then bishop
asics so maybe I need to prepare c5 move
the king with the King better eyes got
h5 father says idiotic it Scott age 5 by
this was stupid and I need to go and
maybe this is not so terrible but this
is not what I planned yeah Bishop c4
mm-hmm I know I know I know we should be
4i min c5 this is what I was trying the
same and I cannot castle long which
would be would be handy
that's not good
check
I Scott rook a five at the end of all
this okay five and my king i have and i
cannot castle anymore ok let's try to
activate mark it's time for some direct
measures i don't i don't think i have
the time for for any King moves and I
need to be quick IAM if he gets the
apron and I don't have anything anything
specific by then I'll be I'll be gone
rook c8 I can take a bishop c8 proxied
bishop CA desrook said so I cannot cover
g4 easily he might be able to play rook
age five but this is I mean this is what
I what I intended just ripped you for
and then I have two active looks at
least not no passive no path of peace he
still should do that probably his rook
f7 defense c7 and g7 so this rookie five
can go porns hunting yes I think this is
the right decision and now maybe c5 what
I want is I want to get the bishop to
deform oh this is this is questionable I
think giving me the bishop on the form I
mean check not saying I'd better or
anything but I wouldn't have done that
let's see how to how to get something
something going in a way he might get
the porn but it's that's not so
important why can I have checks IAM
check here King g6
I'm running right into room three what
the heck yeah and this this I don't know
hmm check Kim check I think the sky he
just wants to have it wrong I mean even
if he can't play for when he does not
want to oh wow really this looks risky
maybe you can do that array that we look
f3m check here Andrew care three let's
rook h8 i mean this is this is a problem
or can I just go to g2 and then I'm
running into the check okay what what is
not playing woke up three what the
mother of all three moves I thought rook
f3 is so simply the only move here and
he played g5 allowing rookie Jade and
Ruby g8 and Jan Dwight is good yeah and
this this is a funny self primo yeah
okay future shouldn't anticipate the
poli playing they only move and it's a
direct change bed that's funny yeah okay
it happens with little time but it was
very obvious I mean what else he didn't
do it it didn't play that King a drive
is really a cool getting it almost into
into a checkmate on the on the side of
the board check yeah and this is how I
sports 25 points again we're to kick
back to to get back to to 275 ah at
least the front end thanks for watching